[Music]
hey guys bleh here what's going on as
you guys are well aware by now TBS was
nice enough to get us a giant orange
cone and blimp they'll be flying all up
and down the East Coast visiting all the
baseball playoffs during the month of
October a lot of fans have expressed a
sadness and depression they are on the
west coast or other parts of the country
and you won't be able to see the cone
and blimp in person well I've got some
good news we begged and begged TBS they
said there was just a little more money
in the budget for a West Coast Konan
blimp ready let's do this here it comes
West Coast cone and blip yep there it is
let's go terrorize some people
[Music]
here comes ya oh man I'm reading the
head how's that feel
blimp terror blimp terror here it comes
yep yep all right definitely breaking
your mother and I leave just as silently
as I come silent like a cat a very loud
cat with a very loud purr
here it goes yep I'm just gonna leave
now just leave in okay there's
definitely air conditioning vent here
[Music]
we go down the right way comes here
comes who likes flips watch Conan
November 8 alright well that will do it
for our West Coast Conan blimp if you
want to see the actual blimp tune into
Team Coco calm slash blimp really easy
to remember and that's it I guess we'll
we'll be seeing more of the West Coast
blimp as time goes on see you guys later
[Music]